the completion of the task is really
important to release the chemicals to
feel like a winner if you've got that
off your plate I wonder how you break it
down for when you're working on the
bigger project so you're working on a
book you've done 80 plus you're your
next when I'm writing best-selling books
so a part of your your most important
thing is hey I'm on a book title I need
to get this done
obviously you'll be able to write an
entire book in the first two hours of a
day so how would you chunk it down so
that you get that feeling you want to
leave feeling like you accomplished
something right that you got something
done you check the box but how would you
break down a bigger goal for the more
time as I I'm assuming that everybody
who is watching this wants to become
rich sooner or later and sooner is
preferable alright the way that you
become rich is you deliver results that
people will pay you for right well one
of the greatest result tools in the
world is called a checklist and a
checklist is very simply a list of every
step in the process from step one to
step two to step three very much like a
recipe that is organized that says this
is what you do to prepare a particular
dish you do these things and you do
these things and you bring out these
things and you take the these
ingredients in this order in this
quantity and so on and you put it all
together so some years ago I did
something which was really quite
ridiculous I wrote a book and I promoted
the heck out of it cost me more to
promote the book that I got from from
royalties or advances and then after
three months they told me that we have
no more interested in promoting your
book and I said well why I mean we're
doing so well interviews blah blah blah
they said well after three months the
window closes is when you write a book
there's a three-month window prior to
the book coming out and three months
after it comes out and then it closes we
go on to other books your book is now
old is an old story it's yesterday's
news and I said well geez what can I do
with that I said I know I'll write a
book every three months and I made that
decision I just I'm just now working
today to finish my 80 second book it'll
be finished by Friday and all with all
those major publishers everyone is
published by major powers no self
publishing
and I'm talking about Simon & Schuster
and while Ian and I have just published
four books with the biggest publisher in
the world penguin Random House and they
came to me and asked for the book so
person says well how do you write a book
I say I take out my checklist and they
say the first thing I need to know we
need to agree on the subject all right
and I only write on a subject that I put
in hundreds of hours of research and
experience the second thing we need to
know is when is the drop-dead date when
are you when do you plan to publish the
book release the book and when do you
have to have it in your hands which is
usually fully six months before the book
is published okay so I work back from
there and then I even got a checklist
now I know what the subject of the book
is when the book has to be in the hands
of the publishers and then I work all
the way back to step one and step when I
and by the way anybody who wants this
just go onto my website Brian Tracy calm
and just to say Brian says check this
for writing it's free and it's 20 points
because people kept asking you how you
write so many books I've written now
four or five books a year for almost for
20 years and I say well I'm out of it
now I'm done this last two months I've
gotten requests for five books for 2017
from this publisher and that publisher
and one brother publisher wants to and I
said geez I said you know I'm gonna take
a break no we want the books because
these books sell they just kind of
tumble over each other one sells in the
second sells and so here's here's the
formula just simply download the formula
like a recipe follow the formula it
takes tremendous discipline to write a
book like III you can appreciate this
because you've written your book your
one word I've said right in a book is
like digging a ditch to the horizon can
you picture that it's you know you just
did you just work and work and you lift
up your head and all you can see is the
horizon you put your head down your work
and work and we're going to look back
and still the horizon out there how or
after hour after hour but you got to get
started well I'm gonna check out the
checklist it took me two years to get
this thing out so I'm envious to get a
new book out every three months maybe
maybe that list will help me too for the
next version thank you for the tips